okay ramona we are here celebrating the
book
of all books on housewives how does it
feel to have some of these reveals out
in the world like you and carol expose
the it's about tom moment being a total
setup
all i know is i got home from being away
in la to promote uh the new peacock show
right the one that's the ultimate girls
vacation and i opened it up and i of
course i went right away to the rhony
parks it's five chapters and let me tell
you something i spit i speed read it
through it it's very entertaining um
dave queen did a phenomenal job i mean
it was very impressive and it's fun
reading and pretty juicy
it's very juicy i have a feeling that
ultimate girls trip is going to be
pretty juicy too judging by that trailer
that's all the first episode and all
anyone was doing was talking about me i
wonder why i wonder why
why do you think that is we see in the
trailer you in kenya having a moment
teresa saying you don't support women i
support women i mean i love supporting
them that's why really my thing i do
actually
why do you think you and kenya got into
it so fast i don't really know i mean we
just kind of like
what heads you know i don't know why and
i was really looking forward to meeting
her and you have to see if we resolved
our issues or not
what do you think is going to surprise
fans about ultimate girls trip did
anything surprise you well how ultimate
it was it was the things we did i mean
the yachts the catamarans um these
horses through the water that were up to
our
knees
i mean every event we did the fireworks
between us and in the sky i mean and
then we had the fun and the laughter the
pajama party it was endless fun and a
little bit of drama
always a little bit of drama we left uh
roni on a bit of a question mark we got
no reunion did you feel like there were
any unanswered questions or things you
wanted to clear up no okay no no
actually what happened was because of um
coven and sonia being a little sick and
everything we actually filmed last
episodes at my house um in southampton
and we resolved all our issues we all
came together so there really was no
reason to do a reunion
well there's a lot of speculation about
where this show goes from here what do
you think the future looks like will you
be sticking around do you think there'll
be new people coming on board well i'll
quote andy cohen i think he was quoted
in one of the magazines saying that we
need to definitely add some people um
listen five people it's not enough you
know we need two or three men and you
know as long as i have fun doing the
show i'm happy to come back i was going
to say when will you know it's time to
hand in your apple because that's always
a question i think when i don't have fun
to me i always say you're good at what
you do if you love what you do and i
love i love doing the show peacock and
i did even during cove that i loved
doing the show we had some ups and downs
but actually i loved it
what do you make of when people though
say well get ramona off this show i
don't agree with her opinions i don't
agree with her point of view
listen it's better to be talked about
than not talked about i don't want to be
a bump on the log perfect is boring
i love it and condolences to you and
avery on coco
that was that was heartbreaking as a dog
lover i can only imagine did sonya break
the news before you were ready to you
know you know that was i don't want to
talk about it makes me too upset let's
not talk about that
well
i hope you can go get your mind off that
have some fun in here good to see you
all the best